tout d'abord monsieur le ministre grâce
à ce que tout le monde appelle le fiasco
de samedi soir le monde entier a pu
découvrir effectivement samedi que la
seine saint denis n'était pas la
californie san lameer contrairement à ce
que disait le président de la république
récemment et moi je ne me réjouis pas de
ces images qui à travers le monde aux
données voilà des images de la france
extrêmement détériorée je pense que
personne ne s'en réjouit alors le stade
de france il a ouvert fin 1998 et la
france elle a changé depuis la fin de
1998 et lorsque le président la
république a effectivement proposé que
la france accueille cette finale dans
des délais courts certes mais on le
savait est ce qu'il a été pourquoi
nappes at-il été mis sous votre égide
monsieur le ministre un comité de
pilotage réunissant au sein de votre
ministère tous les acteurs de cette
manifestation et je dis bien tous cela
peut-être ray éviter aujourd'hui de
consigner ca par marché et de dire que
ça allait mieux marcher demain par
ailleurs je vous ai beaucoup écouter
monsieur ministre lundi midi lundi soir
aujourd'hui et vos propos ont beaucoup
choqué pourquoi un tel déni de votre
part de ce qui s'est réellement passé
pourquoi ne pas mettre les bons mots
derrière ce qui s'est passé pourquoi ne
pas dénoncer la réalité de ce qui s'est
passé et pourquoi ne pas présenter des
excuses aux espagnols et aux onglets ça
n'a pas été fait et enfin je termine au
vu des images qui nous ont tous atterrés
samedi parce que ça nous rajoute
personnes je me pose une question
monsieur ministre avez vous renoncé à
restaurer l'ordre public partout dans
notre pays
[Musique]